(sonnerie)
- Avancer l'heure, reculer
l'heure ou carrément cesser
de le faire. Ce vieux débat qui
refait surface régulièrement
au Canada pourrait bientôt
se régler au sud de notre
frontière.
Le Sénat américain vient
d'adopter le premier projet de
loi pour abolir officiellement
la pratique des changements
d'heure deux fois par année
pour ne conserver qu'un seul
horaire : l'heure avancée d'été.
Et le Sénat, pour une rare fois,
l'a fait à l'unanimité.
Avant d'être appliqué,
le projet de loi devra être
adopté par la Chambre
des représentants et
le président lui-même.
Mais si c'est le cas,
le Canada, qui partage
des milliers de kilomètreslomèts
de frontière avec son principal
partenaire commercial, aurait
tout intérêt à suivre la parade.
Il faut dire que cette pratique
adoptée plus ou moins également
par les provinces canadiennesdee
mondiale a beaucoup de
détracteurs, entre autres parmi
les spécialistes du sommeil.
NADIA GOSSELIN, études du
sommeil, Hôpital sacré-Coeur
- On sait qu'après le changement
d'heure au printemps, il y a
plus d'accidents de la route,
plus d'accidents de travail,
plus de crises cardiaques.
Donc, de manquer une heure
de sommeil, donc d'être privé
d'une heure de sommeil
au printemps, ça a des impacts
au niveapulation.
- Le Sénat américain dit
préférer l'heure avancée,
qui offre une heure de lumière
supplémentaire en fin de
journée, plutôt que l'heure
normale, où le soleil se pointe
plus tôt le matin.
Dans la populatio populatio pos
sont habituellement partagés
entre les lève-tôt et les
couche-tard, mais pour les
expúdhs,@la réponse est simple.
- Au niveau biologique,
donc pour favoriser le sommeil
et l'éveil, c'est préférable
l'heure normale si on considère
toute la population.
- Depuis juin dernier, la
Société canadienne du sommeil
recommande de mettre un terme
aux changements d'heure et de
remettre tout le pays à l'heure
normale.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal